Welcome to Elementary Statistics.
We're really excited
to have you on board.
My name's Katie and
I'm the one who will be explaining most
of the concepts throughout this course.
I'll also be doing a lot of drawing and
a lot of writing to help you understand
the content as much as possible.
in each of the sixteen
lessons in this course,
you'll learn new methods to describe and
analyze data.
Each lesson builds on
the concepts you learned before.
So as you progress through the course,
try to get a good grasp of
the material before moving on.
But if it turns out you need a review,
no big deal.
You can easily go back and rewatch
the videos and redo the exercises.
What do I mean by exercises?
Each lesson consists of short
instructional videos where I explain
cool stat stuff and guide your thinking.
But we want you to make
breakthroughs on your own.
So instead of just telling you a fact or
formula, I'll ask a quiz.
A quiz or exercise, same thing,
is not there for us to judge you or
to impact your grade.
It's there for your own benefit,
to make you think.
At Udacity, we believe that the chance
to think about something from your
own unique perspective is
a powerful learning opportunity.